under normal circumstances i would keep
my mouth shut
but truly we are in desperate times
ladies and gentlemen i just saw
two not one two reports
that we are getting increasingly
polarized and americans
are increasingly less likely to share
their political opinions
with their friends their co-workers
their colleagues people around them
and guys i just can't stand for this
because
and this may come as a shock to you but
in order for us to have a healthy
democracy
we must speak to one another about our
problems so
i know this is a little bit
controversial to say but we need to
start talking
we need to start having a conversation
nay the conversation yes
i know it's brave of me to speak up but
i felt like someone had to do it
so let me say friends neighbors brothers
sisters don't be afraid to share your
political
opinion with your neighbor with your
uncle with your boss
have the courage to reach out across the
aisle
and say hey you're just a guy
or girl i'm here you're there
we can come together as a people and
that's all i wanted to say
uh the video is over
wait you want me to share my political
opinion
not in this climate